okay listen I get something wrong with
me that's the first thing to know I
twitch and shout a lot makes me look
like a damn freak show cut that out
touch it Bailey I'm sorry but inside my
heads an even bigger mess I can't stop
twisting things around words and sounds
especially have to keep playing with
them until they come out right sorry
she's figured I asked like I said a damn
mess then I started working for Frank
Frank men a private eye boys Frank
frankly frankly Frank Oh
he's the one who taught me how to use my
head turn it into his strength he gave
me a place in his crappy world until I
screwed up
[Music]
produces careful now
[Music]
does anybody know what Frank was into on
this there's something going down and
it's big and they were not happy about
what he found we find who did this
we Square accounts if I figure it out
I'm gonna make him regret it I promise
you that that's her that's the girl that
Frank was following I think she found
something what happens to poor people in
this city was a news yesterday and it
won't be tomorrow where's everybody go
mostly just disappear this town is run
by Moses Randolph when someone isn't
seen for what they truly are that's a
very dangerous thing if the first
inkling of power works power is knowing
that you can do whatever you want or not
one person can stop you
those people are invisible they don't
exist if you threaten his work he will
destroy you you're all alone you got no
idea
[Music]
you're webbed up in this somehow and
these people aren't gonna stop it
if you got a head just like my always
turned in things around some people call
it a gift but it's a brain affliction
just to say do you remember what I said
she doesn't know she doesn't know what
don't I know
[Music]
you
you